hey guys what's up so I'm so excited
because they have demos of Super Mario
run at the Apple Store so I'm going to
go in here and I'm going to give it a
try the game going about until December
15th is it really the only way to play
it is to go play the answer
[Music]
obody have to begin all right are you
excited
it's easier with your bigger feel like
that takes away from the experience yeah
it was a good idea theory
what are your initial thoughts so I
think it's pretty cool I know it's one
of those games that you probably just
gonna keep playing over and over and
over and over all right I'm gonna go
back to this beginning one the trial
doesn't really let you do much but I
want to try to get all the pink stars
coins pink points
[Music]
starting your day
No
we got three pink coins
oh yeah guys who did it we got all the
pink points I'm feeling quite quite
completed oh no now it turns the purple
whoops oh God
so now I got to find all of the purple
coins I've been looking but it gets so
much more difficult as you progress so
as you see the level has now changed and
the purple coin is oh shoot see I miss
it already
we retry yes
purple coin like look how hard this one
is
[Music]
where the heck is that purple one day it
take me back as far as I want
[Music]
I don't even know where it's at what do
you guys get the point that was Super
Mario run they have it here as a demo at
the Apple store and it's actually really
fun I thought it was going to be kind of
basic which yes it is basic or what it
was getting super addictive because
every time you collect all the same
color coins you then carry on and it
brings you to another level
we're get the one difficulty flex our
color I'm not really sure how many of
those there are well the man won't let
me know what you guys think of the game
and I will see you in my next video so
sorry I haven't been posting much I have
been so sick the past couple of days
today basically only been playing mobile
game do you guys have any suggestions
for games I could play leave me some
down in the comments below
they can also be android games because
now I've got a pixel developer so I'll
see you guys later
so mistakes were made I screwed up
would you get under the tree nothing box
of coal gosh I love holidays do you like
Rosalina do you want her to be your mom
does she look like your mom does she
look like your mom